vous êtes dur en affaires les gars c'est
juste la conspiration des gens mal à
l'aise moi j'ai une boîte de prod je te
propose de jouer dans un film tu
accepterait en vrai ou pas mais moi je
te propose qu'on fasse ça en fait
sérieux
[Musique]
salut pierre salut ça va très bien ravi
d'être là c'est le plaisir de te
recevoir mais avec plaisir écoute merci
d'ailleurs aussi les mêmes cadeaux qui
nous accueillent aujourd'hui tu te sens
prêt je suis born really comme on dit
let's go c'est parti et une roue qui va
tourner avec des emoji je t'invite à
appuyer quand tu veux sur le buzzer ok
on va voir sur quoi ça s'arrête
ta visé un truc particulier c'est un
popcorn ça tombe bien on va voir ce qui
se cache derrière ensemble et je te
propose de commenter ou de réagir alors
si affiche de comédie qui ont l'air
plutôt des comédies familiales avec je
dirais un thème enfin une une
identité visuelle que commune qui est le
titre en jaune jaune et blanc jaune et
bleu souvent aussi c'est ça donc oui bah
c'est ouais tu veux dire quoi c'est
fréquent non il y en a pas une que j'ai
eu dis toi si j'ai vu the boyfriend avec
d'ailleurs pas une comédie française qui
est la seule oui pour l'histoire c'est
visuel avait été partagé par Vincent
Cassel ah oui qu'en 2018 alors lui il
était allé de façon assez dure l'année
dénoncer une forme de formatage de la
Comédie française aujourd'hui etc etc
toi qu'est-ce que ça t'inspire est-ce
que tu penses qu'il y a une un style
français de comédie c'est une bonne
question je pense que ça va se
diversifier et je suis assez confiant
dans l'avenir parce que je trouve qu'on
a de des auteurs et des réalisateurs
vraiment jeunes et de Tal qui vont faire
de la comédie différemment différente
c'est sûr que pour que les spectateurs
s'y retrouve aussi moi je comprends que
parfois on réutilise forcément des codes
pour que qui sont maintenant ancrés dans
le l'imaginaire et l'inconscient
collectif pour qu'on comprenne de quoi
on parle mais comme il y a des
miniatures sur Youtube par exemple
complètement le côté fit and fun avec
tout le monde qui rigole le titre en
énorme bon bah c'est voyager il y a des
codes mais les codes ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils ont fait pour
être cassés et en France on a des
comédies aussi différentes que la
ch'tite famille et que la cité de la
peur donc moi je crois qu'on est très
drôle en France franchement je dis et
parce que moi j'ai plein de français
dont je suis fan et qui me font beaucoup
rire quand je cite la cité de la peur je
pense évidemment à Alain Chabat là on
l'a dit mascarade c'est comme une forme
de comédie comment tu les choisis
comment tu dis celui-là je trouve ça je
trouve ça dur la comédie dur à écrire
dur de faire une bonne comédie puis
aussi un certain snobisme peut-être
autour de la comédie qui veut que quand
tu es un peu cinéphile ou un peu on va
dire intelligent la comédie même si tu
ris à la fin tu fais ouais enfin bon ça
vaut pas un film dramatique alors que
moi j'ai défendu la comédien en disant
c'est un style difficile c'est un style
très généreux c'est un exercice assez
violent et inhumain de se dire je vais
faire rire une salle je vais faire rire
des gens je vais te faire rire donc je
trouve que ça devrait être presque plus
récompensé alors la récompense c'est
souvent les entrées parce que c'est
quand ça marche bien ça il y a du monde
mais le rire est souvent associé au côté
populaire mais du coup plus facile
peut-être que faire réfléchir ou je ne
sais quoi dans un alors qu'en plus on
peut faire réfléchir via une comédie
exactement Chaplin Molière on en parlait
de Molière et deux secondes c'est ils
nous ont prouvé que c'était totalement
possible moi j'aime ces comédies là les
choisir bah c'est vrai que de plus en
plus je commence à les produire parce
que j'adore la comédie depuis toujours
il y a beaucoup de gens et de choses qui
me font rire et j'ai envie de réunir
dans des séries ou des films donc là je
commence à produire ça là je coproduit
une série pour Netflix de comédie trop
bien voilà et je suis ravi de le faire
donc j'aime bien accompagner des
comédies aussi d'autres films aussi avec
ma boîte de production et c'est le début
donc c'est très excitant on passe à la
question suivante si ça te dit je
relance du coup la roue je t'invite à
appuyer sur le buzzer quand tu veux
c'est un dé le hasard c'est le hasard
mais c'est plus un jeu là je crois
ensemble c'est un tu préfères classique
ok mais sur des questions diverses et
variées qu'on va découvrir ensemble on
va voir le premier
un petit rôle au théâtre et je pense que
c'est bien de le faire graduellement
donc je conseillerais le théâtre pour
commencer et le cinéma c'est un art plus
jeune plus nouveau donc il y a une forme
peut-être d'excitation autre mais
j'adore les deux non je peux pas choisir
c'est trop bien on va passer au suivant
je crois qu'il y a un autre tu préfères
la réponse j'avoue qu'elle est voilà
j'ai cru comprendre que les lunettes
avaient un rôle important pour décrocher
un premier rôle sur les Saint-Laurent
notamment c'est vrai donc des fois j'en
remets vous voyez c'est mes lunettes de
vue je suis myope mais c'est vrai que
j'ai porté des lunettes à un shooting
gala j'avais vraiment les 19 ans et
c'était mon premier shooting photo donc
j'étais un peu nerveux et tout il y
avait plein d'accessoires ils m'ont dit
choisi une paire de lunettes enfin non
ils m'ont pas dit ils m'ont dit choisi
l'accessoire que tu veux et il y avait
plein de trucs et moi je dis oh ça
pourrait être marrant je mettre ses
lunettes ils m'ont dit oh ouais si tu
veux pourquoi pas et tout en plus donc
pourquoi pas trop loin de moi j'ai
vraiment des lunettes d'habitude et tout
et du coup je les ai mis j'ai fait les
photos et plus tard j'ai compris que
c'est presque ça qui m'a valu
le rôle en tout cas l'intérêt fort de
Jalil l'espère qui a réalisé Yves Saint
Laurent il a vu cette photo il a dit
pourquoi pas ce gars
en Yves Saint Laurent exactement
prochain tu préfères je crois qu'il en
reste un ou deux
vous êtes dur en affaires les gars voilà
j'avoue que sans contexte c'est très
bizarre quand même deux bon c'est
d'autres très grandes actrices déjà mais
clairement Isabelle Adjani j'ai rêvé de
tourner avec elle toute ma vie et là
c'est arrivé elle est dans la salle elle
est dans mascarade et on a des scènes
incroyables ensemble et j'étais plus
qu'aux anges
c'est que la première fois que j'ai
entendu la voix d'Adjani je vais me la
péter pendant 2 secondes mais elle m'a
laissé un message sur mon portable que
du coup j'ai gardé qui est dans un dans
un disque dur dans un dans un placard
fermé chez moi parce qu'il y avait sa
voix je la connaissais pas et c'était
après un homme idéal et elle m'avait
fait des compliments magnifiques donc
Isabelle on a une histoire particulière
et surtout d'avoir tourné ce film
ensemble et surtout mon admiration
totale pour la femme qui est équilibre
qui s'engage sur des sujets aussi
au-delà du cinéma Jennifer Lawrence
c'est mon crush ultime donc c'est encore
autre chose une grande amitié oui belle
amitié je racontais ça sur mes réseaux
effectivement que la rencontre c'est
catastrophiques j'ai été très très mal
introduit par un mec qui parlait
absolument pas anglais ou une cascade de
merde oui qui ont fait que finalement on
sait même serrer la main
allant je ne peux même pas décrire comme
ça on sait serrer la main comme ça de
gêne l'un et l'autre de timidité et je
pense qu'elle est aussi elle était
absolument pas timide de demander parce
qu'elle n'avait aucune dette qui j'étais
mais juste timide de la du malaise de la
situation oui de ça arrive souvent comme
toi ça arrive souvent d'être face à des
gens qui parfois sont gênants et juste
sur lui il y a un coup de machin et je
l'ai recroiser à New York et j'ai failli
avoir l'audace de lui dire où ils
mettent un louis shook the back over
hands tellement c'était gênant notre
rencontre et que depuis c'est un
cauchemar pour moi
je pense pas elle rencontrait tellement
ça fait très sec tout c'est un truc
conspiration sauf que c'est juste la
conspiration des gens mal à l'aise
assez mal à l'aise pour faire ça et on
n'a pas rectifié c'est ce que je raconte
dans l'anecdote sur mes réseaux on a
fait ça et on a pas rectifié le truc on
se fait toujours on a fait tous les deux
gens c'est normal c'est la vie normale
on est des Sims mal programmé
très bien je crois qu'il en reste hein
j'adore attendez mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que cet été c'est sur comment
s'appelle ce truc c'est l'intelligence
artificielle exactement on a fait le
sexe stable diffusion il y a on a tapé
on a fait ça hier de taper pierre nine
AZT je suis ou Pierre nine a the dog ce
qui est drôle ce que je comprends pas
que c'est bien c'est qui pourquoi ils
vont pas chercher des photos juste une
photo ça c'est pas moi on dirait un
autre gars je comprends pas ce qu'elle
foutent et surtout on a réussi à faire
toi avec quelque chose qui ressemble un
truc de chien mais on n'a pas réussi à
faire de toi un arbre tu es devant
l'arbre
jouer un arbre ou jouer un chien je
jouerai toujours un chien j'adore les
chiens ils me passionne depuis Didier ça
a relancé à fond ma passion que j'avais
déjà enfant et Didier le film avec Alain
Chabat qui est extraordinaire ça me tes
premiers rôles au théâtre aussi
personne voulait du rôle du chien au
lycée et mon stylé il y avait une fille
qui avait pleuré même devant tout le
monde devant le genre toute l'option
théâtre et il y a du monde j'étais à
Claude Monet dans le 13e et elle avait
fondu en larmes en disant il y a mes
parents qui viennent il y avait pas tu
peux pas le un chien et tout moi j'ai
dit moi je le fais j'avais vu Didier
j'étais trop chaud j'étais là bah cool
et je veux être le chien quoi mais alors
que je joue un arbre c'est vrai que j'ai
fait deux trois ans de théâtres et ils
t'ont fait jouer mais j'ai l'impression
que tout le monde à l'occasion de faire
l'arbre c'est vraiment un poteau qui on
dit c'est l'arbre il faut déjà j'aime
beaucoup ta démarche c'est plus bref
chien figure-toi c'est plus bref chien
mais j'aime beaucoup plus allemand mais
figure-toi que je sais pas pourquoi il y
a ce cliché de jouer là parce que moi on
me l'a pas fait faire voir on ne l'a
jamais fait faire mais c'est peut-être
une première étape pour désinhiber parce
qu'il y a beaucoup besoin de désinhiber
les gens c'est surtout ça le théâtre au
début après je joue un arbre mais à
jouer une feuille ça peut être autre
chose aussi ça peut être un autre projet
à chaque fois c'est le truc qui revient
j'ai fait trois ans de conservateur
National d'Art Dramatique de Paris j'ai
fait 5 ans de comédie française la
question qu'on me pose le plus c'est
fait
dans la rue les gens t'arrêtes ils
disent finan et docteur juif c'est
beaucoup beaucoup ça mais j'adore comme
on disait au début de l'interview moi
j'adore la comédie donc si les gens ils
se rattache à ça ça me va très bien
alors on lance la roue ça te va aller je
t'invite à l'arrêter quand tu veux
et ça se stoppe sur un micro alors on va
voir ce qu'il y a derrière je ne suis
pas un jouet je suis une cuillette
j'étais fait pour la soupe la salade
peut-être un petit peu ça
je ne me rappelais plus ouais j'étais
sur un tagulé je te demande pas du coup
qu'est-ce qu'on vient de t'entendre Toy
Story 4 fameuse couchette tu as doublé
dans beaucoup de dessins animés au film
en tout genre c'est quand même jeune tu
en as fait beaucoup comment tu
l'expliques ça fait longtemps que tu
voulais faire ça ou en vrai oui comme
plein d'acteurs le rêve de faire des
dessins animés de cette liberté là et
puis c'était surtout moi je l'ai fait
quand on m'a offert l'occasion de
rejoindre un peu des trucs légendaires
pour moi donc il y a toy story donc Toy
Story bon voilà je fais pas de dessin
pour c'est j'ai grandi avec ça j'adore
vraiment des chefs-d'oeuvre ensuite vice
versa vraiment
l'ADN Pixar par excellence intelligent
pour tous les âges donc je ne pouvais
pas refuser puis en plus c'est
l'occasion de rencontrer tout Pixar
parce qu'on est on est allé à Cannes
avec le Film Festival de Cannes et puis
ensuite j'ai fait aussi cro-man qui est
le studio Harman et qui est un studio
remarquable qui a fait notamment Wallace
et Gromit ou Shaun le Mouton et qui sont
pareils intelligents drôles très
universel donc quand il y a des super
aventures avec des super artistes j'y
vais pourquoi on me l'a autant proposé
je sais pas mais merci continuer j'adore
il y en aura peut-être d'autres
peut-être d'autres après écoute vu que
toi tu es fort en doublage que moi je
parle d'actualité sur la chaîne on va
découvrir ensemble très très peur là
mais découvrir ensemble un reportage de
Lina alors j'ai pas été en tête mais ça
date il y a fort longtemps je te propose
d'essayer de le doubler oh là oh là oh
là oh là comme tu dis alors sachant que
là ça reportage de Lina sur les leçons
de triche pour le bac
tellement de ça va être très connu
ça reportage sur la leçon de triche pour
le bac j'ai rien droit d'entendre c'est
comme ça alors en plus Macron en plus
Emmanuel Macron qui joue tennis Emmanuel
Macron s'il est un tennisman avisé il
est aussi un sacré tricheur et voilà
pourquoi aujourd'hui au lycée Charles de
mieux la triche a pris ses quartiers le
stylo farci ce nom est exceptionnel le
stylo farci qu'on y met de la viande ou
des antisèches il fonctionne de la même
manière dans votre sac le fameux
sakamalyse n'a-t-il pas qu'elles
ressentir très longtemps n'a-t-il pas
caché une copie qu'a-t-il mis dans son
Bristol à punaise j'ai l'impression que
c'est que des films de Audiard c'est que
des répliques de Audiard eh avec ton
Bristol a pu neige je vais te faire la
tête au carré mon gars c'est très dur en
vrai extrêmement difficile on est
extrêmement bien sorti surtout que là il
y a eu zéro visionnage avant c'est c'est
très dur les noms sont incroyables
j'aurais préféré te faire j'ai une
passion pour la mauvaise le mauvais
doublage ça ça me passionne et depuis
que je suis petit là en fait la VF la
mauvaise VF ou les je trouve que des
doubleurs ont pris des codes on parlait
de code des affiches tout à l'heure les
codes de doublage presque de mettre trop
d'intention dans une phrase très simple
genre les gars qu'est-ce que vous êtes
venus faire dans ce parking on dirait
que vous êtes là depuis des heures oh là
là me dites pas que vous êtes en train
de te dealer de la drogue c'est un dire
gave pourquoi simple qui parle vraiment
comme ça en fait c'est de la daube et ça
m'a toujours fasciné et j'adore ça et le
mauvais le mauvais pardon le mauvais
doublage avec les lèvres aussi genre tu
vois bien qu'il y fuck mais nous on lui
fait dire merde tu vois ça donne genre
non [ __ ] de merde merde ça j'ai
toujours adoré comme ça c'est voilà ça
marche dans un dessin animé ou un truc
mais c'est vrai que dans un doublage
d'une série américaine et en même temps
c'est mon péché mignon j'adore je
voudrais pas qu'ils arrêtent donc
n'arrêtez pas trop vite
très fort trop trop en tout cas tu
connais très très bien sorti j'ai j'ai
fait ce que j'ai mon rôle suivant je
t'invite à appuyer toujours
quand tu vas casser la machine oh c'est
une bulle tu vas devoir doublée
game ok c'est une citation spacieux
c'est une citation du film que je
reconnais de mascarade les très riches
crèvent d'ennuis les riches font
semblant d'être très riches et quand à
tous les autres ils crèvent de jalousie
ok donc c'est effectivement une citation
qu'on retrouve dans dans mascara je
crois même que les dons la bande-annonce
tout à fait j'ai vu le film quand même
mais déjà merci à toi c'est pas tous les
journalistes non ouais c'est une
citation alors c'est une description un
peu acerbe de la Côte d'Azur de ce qui
s'y joue on sait qu'il y a beaucoup de
bling bling on sait que de Saint-Tropez
à Cannes en passant par Nice la French
Riviera brille et attire beaucoup de
gens qui aiment tout ce qui brillent
et je pense que ça raconte aussi assez
bien
le regard que Nicolas Bedos pose sur la
vacuité de ces endroits là on peut aussi
penser Ibiza on peut aussi penser à
Dubaï
petit big up aux influenceurs c'est la
même chose c'est effectivement des gens
qui voudraient être qui ne sont pas je
pense moi que au-delà de cette citation
ce qui m'intéresse là-dedans c'est qu'on
veut toujours ce qu'on a pas est-ce que
Hugo tu as l'impression de vouloir ce
que tu as pas au quotidien quand je fais
une comédie je finis en faisant malade
que c'est du drame que je veux faire et
dès qu'on me dit ah ton dernier drame il
était génial j'ai dit ouais mais je sais
faire de la comédie aussi et en fait ça
peut être sain comme ça peut devenir
très malsain et le film raconte quand tu
désires ce que ce que tu as pas
constamment inlassablement ça devient
malsain et là on parle du coup des Très
Riches crèvent d'ennuis des riches qui
font semblant d'être très riches et de
du reste de la population ensuite qui
crève de jalousie mais est-ce que elle
est pas légitime finalement cette forme
de jalousie parce que l'ennui la
capacité à se dire je suis riche je suis
trop bien je ouais après ceux qui
crèvent d'ennuis je pense qu'ils sont
pas bien et ils sont sous
antidépresseurs ceux du milieu qui font
semblant d'être très riche je les
comparerai peut-être à cela va être
d'Instagram de vouloir montrer une vie
parfaite tout le temps alors qu'en fait
on ferait peut-être mieux la plupart du
temps d'assumer que bah il y a plein de
trucs qui merde et qu'en fait ça fait
aussi partie c'est super il y a plein de
sportifs en ce moment et de gens qui
prennent la parole sur le fait que même
si tu devrais aller bien pour toi bah
les problèmes psychologiques
psychiatriques ça existe bon ça fait
partie de la thématique pour moi et
ensuite tous ceux qui crèvent de
jalousie bah j'ai envie de dire en fait
le film et c'est pour ça que je trouve
vraiment intéressant mascarade parce que
ça ça parle de lutte sociale aussi quand
même beaucoup et de gens qui veulent
escalader grimper la montée dans cet
ascenseur social et sortir de leurs
conditions à savoir là de gigolos marine
vact et le personnage que je joue Adrien
ceux qui crèvent de jalousie évidemment
moi je crois qu'ils ont c'est tout
naturel de crever de jalousie c'est
juste parce qu'on est dans une société
où on
va dire capitaliste qui te propose
toujours des choses non-stop on nous met
des choses sous le nez en nous disant
qu'on on a besoin et en nous perçoitant
qu'on en a besoin et du coup crever de
jalousie avec les autres c'est dur c'est
dur de ne pas crever de jalousie quand
on voit la différence de statut et
surtout ce que nous fait miroiter cette
société on va passer à la question
question suivante je passe je relance la
roue vas-y quand tu veux
tu tentes de laisser appuyer
on peut j'ai des techniques très
différentes à chaque fois l'approche
très différentes là en l'occurrence
c'est un chronomètre alors c'est le même
le même format le même truc qu'on a fait
avec les candidats à la présidentielle
pendant l'élection ou Bill Gates
récemment c'était le dernier de passer
ça me paraît tout naturel que ce soit
moi un chrono qui va s'afficher de 60
secondes en 60 secondes je dois te poser
un maximum de questions ok je te laisse
répondre le plus possible par oui ou par
non je commence est-ce que tu sens prêt
je me sens prêt let's go feuille man
est-ce que c'est ton projet de l'année
oh la vache non mais vous êtes dur oui
et non la comédie est-ce que c'est mieux
que le drame non dans le film mascarade
tu te barres d'un resto sans payer
est-ce que c'était déjà arrivé en vrai
non est-ce que tu as déjà vu des acteurs
s'endormir au César oui dans mascarade
est ton personnage a le mal de mer
est-ce que tu as le mal de mer j'ai fait
l'Antarctique une fois j'étais pas fière
tu conseillerais docteur juif un pote
non enfin un pote que j'aime bien en
tout cas au Festival de Cannes est-ce
que le plus important c'est les soirées
non et ça c'est dur maintenant est-ce
que le cinéma pollue trop oui sans doute
oui est-ce que tu as déjà regretté
d'avoir joué dans un film
non est-ce que tu as peur de prendre
l'avion
moins qu'avant ça va mieux je me soigne
dans mascarade on nous dit que c'est
impossible de se frapper soi-même et ce
que tu as déjà essayé on peut mais très
fort ouais très fort je pense pas ok
est-ce que le cinéma c'est mieux que le
théâtre non ok j'en ai encore une ou
deux est-ce que tu es vraiment fan des
Spice Girls oui oui tu aimerais devenir
réalisateur oui une petite dernière pour
la route peut-être est-ce que les
récompenses c'est nécessaire pour
devenir un grand acteur non DiCaprio
les meilleurs films qu'est-ce qu'il
devrait changer d'ailleurs dans ce genre
de cérémonie on peut penser au César
mais c'est en général dans l'esprit lié
au chemin moi je pense qu'il faut le
tourner vers le public c'est-à-dire si
on veut le télé diffuser télé diffuser
vraiment une expression que mon rap a
dit
si on veut le télévisé et même
d'ailleurs le diffuser sur internet
évidemment je pense qu'il faut
réinventer la formule pour que ce soit
moins long plus festif plus jovial comme
je disais mais sinon c'est pas mal il y
a déjà il y a eu des années où c'était
génial il y a des années où moi j'ai
passé des super bon évidemment les
années avec des gros films intouchables
les années Valérie Lemercier les années
ou shabbat prenaient une super place
même Jérôme Commandeur avait fait un taf
incroyable il y a une bonne formule à
trouver on est tellement
malin et je veux dire les Français sur
l'humour sur le divertissement il faut
juste trouver la bonne formule
question suivante pour ça on relance la
roue et je t'invite
on va voir ce qui s'affiche derrière
c'est une photo ou une image on va voir
ce qu'il y a alors
un magazine bon écoute forcément vu pire
couve de l'année
en septembre 2022 elle était pas mal
critiquée sur les réseaux sociaux est-ce
que tu comprends pourquoi oui bah
totalement à juste titre
bah en fait bon j'en ai déjà parlé un
petit peu là en faisant la promotion à
la radio et fire mais j'ai aucun aucun
problème à m'exprimer limite je suis
content qu'on me pose la question parce
que on s'est retrouvé à faire une photo
au Congrès des exploitants qui a un
congrès où il y a tous les distributeurs
de films donc il y avait à ce
rendez-vous faut imaginer des dizaines
et des dizaines de distributeurs qui
venaient présenter plein de films
différents donc pâté représenté par
Jérôme Seydoux qui au milieu de la photo
et Pathé ce jour-là Virginie Efira était
invité marine vague qui était invité le
concours de circonstances ça fait qu'on
s'est retrouvé que des mecs à faire
cette photo et qui nous ont on a dit bah
c'est pas très féminin tout de suite on
s'est fait la remarque entre nous et on
a dit bah si on fait la photo elle est
dans le magazine avec les autres les
autres distributeurs ils nous ont dit
oui oui c'est dans le magazine il y a
tous les autres distributeurs tous les
autres filles dans le magazine mais sur
La Une et finalement évidemment c'est ce
que je disais à la radiologie je disais
en fait quand on essaie de contrôler
notre image on passe pour des relous et
quand on lâche 5 cm de de l'Est et ben
il se passe ça et il se passe ça alors
non seulement on nous a mis en couvre
sans nous demander en plus on s'est
retrouvé en cours en utilisant notre
image avec un titre à moitié ambigu voir
nauséabond si on pense qu'il a déjà été
utilisé par d'autres gens vraiment
douteux aux opinions douteuses et le
pompon c'est que du coup tout ça
maintenant symbolise un truc en
couverture comme si ça représentait un
cinéma alors que moi c'est pas du tout
le cinéma ni dont je rêve ni je pense au
cinéma actuel en France vu les la
diversité beaucoup plus grande et et les
grandes réalisatrices et actrices qu'on
a donc je l'ai trouvé ça j'ai trouvé ça
j'étais atterré aussi autant que les
internautes quand il a découvertes et
au-delà de mon cette une on soit ça pose
une question plus large évidemment c'est
la question de de la représentation de
la population dans le cinéma il y a des
choses selon toi qu'on peut faire pour
améliorer justement cette question de
santé de diversité en termes de je pense
oui il y a plein il y a plein plein de
choses je pense que maintenant je vois
parce que comme je produis un peu je
vois que dans la tête des producteurs
des scénaristes des distributeurs il y a
quand même vraiment un nouvel élan et
une nouvelle
prise de conscience prise de conscience
si elle n'était pas nouvelle elle était
déjà là mais en tout cas elle est
renforcée donc en fait c'est en train de
faire son chemin ça va jamais assez vite
parce que c'est du retard donc le retard
tu peux jamais le rattraper réellement
mais il faut il faut qu'on ait tous ça
en tête et puis les derniers les
derniers Grands Prix qui ont été
distribués je pense au film de Ready one
je pense évidemment à titane bon bah
c'est c'est le cours normal des choses
en fait qui est en train de se mettre en
place et ça devrait être fait depuis des
millénaires j'ai envie de dire mais donc
c'est nécessaire et c'est en train de se
passer et c'est bien trop bien on va
passer à la question suivante nouvelle
roue nouveau buzzer je te laisse buzzer
c'est bien que ça tombe jamais sur le
même truc c'est quand même une chance
c'est fou alors que pourtant c'est
vraiment relié à rien non mais c'est
elle est connecté en Bluetooth
on le fera après écouter parce que
j'espère que ça va fonctionner
aujourd'hui je pense que ça va se
reconnaître non on a préféré
en plus
okivre
c'est pas mal alors qu'est-ce qui se
cache derrière on va le découvrir
ensemble écoute
mascarade définition
non féminin une mascarade c'est un alors
ça peut être la bonne définition c'est
un jeu de dupe non c'est faux
j'aime bien ce jeu ou tu dis aux gens
allez-y allez-y
non c'est bah en vrai la définition je
la connais pas mais je sais que ça
serait il y a une des définitions ça se
rapproche ça se rapproche de du bal
masqué ok oui
mais moi j'aurais dit que c'est une
effectivement c'est une un jeu de dupe
et un jeu de masque évidemment parce
qu'on a le mot masque et une supercherie
ouais je pense en fait elle est deux
trois définitions qu'on retrouve
divertissement ou les participants sont
déguisés déguisement à coudrement et le
troisième évidemment c'est le côté
comedy hypocrite mise en scène trompeuse
c'est surtout ça dont on parle en tout
cas dans le film actuellement bien sûr
mais il y a le côté déguisé masqué aussi
parce que déjà le film commence sur une
grande fête et je tiens à dire ça aussi
le film est très généreux en images la
Côte d'Azur les belles villas les belles
voitures c'est vraiment Nicolas voulait
faire un grand film de cinéma qui fait
qui fait voyager et ça commence
notamment par un bal un bal masqué ou en
fait chacun joue déjà des rôles moi je
joue le gigolo de cette je fais semblant
d'être en couple avec cette dame plus
âgée ancienne star du cinéma elle-même
passe une audition déguisée en années 20
pour un mec qui fait semblant d'être
fidèle mais qui est déjà pas fidèle pour
une fille qui fait comme si elle était
invitée alors qu'elle est on est en
train de voler des bijoux et d'arnaquer
tout le monde donc il y a déjà une
grosse mascarade dès le début et c'est
pas que ouais une mise en scène jusqu'au
masque dès le départ qu'on retrouve avec
arnaque sous le soleil quoi une grosse
une grosse arnaque qui commence dès le
début je fais quel parallèle avec le
métier d'acteur en tant que tel est-ce
que quand tu es acteur tu
explore des choses que tu aurais jamais
exploré déjà des métiers aussi tu vois
moi j'ai appris à faire du chocolat du
cheval à m'entraîner avec les
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris de la danse
pour ce film là trois mois de danse donc
c'est très c'est très riche humaine quoi
c'est et dans quelle mesure est-ce que
c'est des les rôles que tu prends il y a
quand même toujours une part de toi
est-ce que tu as déjà fait des rôles ou
si tu dis mais c'est pas du tout moi
mais je vais quand même le jouer
il y en a des plus loin il y en a des
plus loin c'est sûr que
l'engagement
j'avais pas pensé à suivre en premier
c'est flippant mais oui pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu je joue dans Goliath un
lobby ce qui défend les pesticides et
qui argumente justement pour convaincre
tout le monde que il faut continuer à
fond dans les pesticides complètement
toi c'est complètement moi au quotidien
mais non non c'est vrai que Goliath
typiquement j'ai peu de choses en commun
mais c'est un père de famille aimant et
aimé et donc j'ai quand même ça j'ai
quand même une humanité à défendre
derrière ça et en fait si tu veux pas
défendre ton personnage il faut toujours
vouloir le défendre même quand tu joues
un meurtrier triple récidiviste en fait
il va falloir trouver non pas comment le
défendre pour que tout le monde le
pardonne mais trouver en fait ce qui en
fait un humain parce que c'est un être
humain donc à partir du moment où tu
joues pas un droïde et il faut pouvoir
défendre quand même la part d'humanité
du gars il y a des rôles et des
personnages qui sont plus durs à
incarner pour que d'autres oui bien sûr
je pense que Yves Saint Laurent par
exemple c'était il y avait beaucoup de
choses à mettre ensemble c'est une
exigence aussi avec une figure qui est
connue ou forcément tu dois que les gens
attendent je voulais te répondre sur
autre chose c'était quoi c'était oui et
ce que je reconnais le métier d'actueux
j'aimerais bien doubler un extrait
non
jusque parfois quand je rencontre des
gens quand j'étais pas en couple quand
je daisais des meufs souvent elle disait
ouais mais tu es un acteur je sais pas
si je peux te faire confiance parce que
tu es un menteur et tout et ça
t'assimilation de l'acteur au menteur
j'ai jamais aimé ça
en règle générale je veux dire parce que
ce truc cliché de les acteurs il manque
bien et tout moi c'est pas vrai je suis
nul au loup-garou je suis le premier
gars qu'on repère je peux même pas jouer
avec mes potes il m'exclut du jeu parce
qu'ils disent on voit direct quand tu es
loup-garou parce que tu risques et
rouges et tout c'est catastrophique mais
ça ça m'intéresse parce que c'est vrai
que je pourrais avoir le même le même
truc le côté bah ouais c'est un acteur
bah forcément il sait comment je sais
pas si tu veux faire le mec heureux il
fera le mec heureux si je peux faire le
mec en fait c'est
plus j'ai pas envie de reconnaître
forcément les façons qu'il a de jouer
mais j'ai envie de reconnaître pour le
la raison du choix et c'est souvent les
bons choix qui font des bons acteurs je
trouve et là si on faisait un mascara du
coup tu as le sentiment d'avoir du te
changer pas mal pour incarner ce
j'espère oui déjà oui le point commun
c'est un artiste là où je pouvais
m'identifier c'est si on coupait les
ailes et qu'on empêchait lui on empêche
de danser enfin il peut plus danser
parce qu'il est blessé et ça l'a ça l'a
brisé quoi moi si on empêche de jouer je
serais malheureux forcément très
malheureux et du coup là-dessus je me je
retrouve je comprends Adrien maintenant
sur le côté quelqu'un qui est très au
début du film très
prostré très dans la désillusion dans la
déception de lui-même de sa vie et donc
dans l'alcool dans la weed et tout ça ça
me ressemble pas énormément
ça c'est vraiment pas
on a compris c'est assez central on va
tenter quelque chose
c'est pas un doublage en gros on va
avoir des noms de films qui font
s'afficher à l'écran on va essayer de
deviner en une phrase on va pas faire un
truc trop long mais en une phrase le
scénario potentiel de ce film mais à
partir d'un juste un titre exactement on
va découvrir le premier ensemble je les
découvre aussi
de Lina encore ok le balai bleu et bah
le balai bleu oh la vache tu as une idée
toi on comprend montage si on est loin
le balai bleu c'est tout simplement un
film je l'ai vu donc je peux en parler
c'est un film qui parle justement d'un
ballet magique qui apparaît en fait qui
est qui passe de propriétaire en
propriétaire en fait et donc dans les
années 40 et magique quoi ouais il a
plusieurs
il passe l'aspirateur oui oui c'est
comme en fait c'est une fille ça lui
permet de voler il y a un mec ça lui
permet de faire le ménage beaucoup plus
vite il y a il y en a un autre ça
devient un personnage le ballet lui
parle donc il s'est inspiré d'Harry
Potter pour faire quoi plus ou moins il
y avait attends tu me dis pas le vrai
pitch c'est horrible il y en a pas je
crois on doit juste inventer des pitchs
vous foutez de moi mais on a des droits
ça s'aime là-dessus et ça c'est ça se
trouve il y a une bonne idée que la
démarreur attendez j'en ai pas à l'abri
ah c'est vous qui avez inventé ce type
de merde ah ben je comprends mieux c'est
suivant on va voir je découvre aussi la
chute d'éthi c'est un très très très bon
film ça le titre est pas ouf mais le
film ouais le film est vachement bien en
fait les Thierry c'est pas le prénom
c'est le nom de famille d'une famille
ouais c'est Frédéric Thierry et
Jean-Baptiste Thierry qui sont des
frères et en fait ça raconte comment ils
sont arrivés au sommet en faisant de la
magie à Las Vegas et avec des tigres et
des des perroquets et tout machin il
faisait des trucs incroyables
incroyables ça s'inspiré d'une histoire
vraiment en plus ouais et c'est réalisé
par mail melbrooks et en fait ils sont
c'est avec Bradley Cooper très jeune
et en fait ça raconte comment la famille
ensuite est plongée dans le
deal de drogue la coke et tout et en
fait à partir de ce moment-là les tours
de magie à la fin c'était plus que tu
vois c'était ça quoi il faisait ça sur
les trucs du pouce coupé il faisait des
trucs avec des sucres que tu gardes dans
la paume de la main bizarre
donc c'est les Thierry c'est en fait ça
rise and fall de la famille c'est trop
fort et tu es très très bon là c'est un
vrai film c'est pas que je suis bon là
c'est bon vous mettez que des vrais
films
et on va devoir deviner le titre
potentiel de suivre let's go Hugo est un
youtubeur
Hugo est un youtubeur passionné par
l'actualité un jour sa chaîne Youtube
d'un virgule 5 millions d'abonnés et
supprimer sans explication le jeune
homme se lance alors à la poursuite des
responsables dans cette injustice très
mal lu le jeune homme se lance alors à
la poursuite des responsables de cette
injustice à ces risques et périls
attends je l'ai le titre c'est
Hugo des risques ouais pas mal j'avais
Hugo des crimes parce que à la fin il
tue des gens carrément oh ok fort Hugo
décrire c'est parfait j'aime bien
scénario j'aime pas l'idée est-ce que tu
jouerais dedans est-ce que moi j'ai une
boîte de prod je te propose de jouer
dans un film accepterait en vrai ou pas
à jouer mon propre rôle peut-être pas
c'est là mais un autre si tu veux jouer
oui d'ailleurs ton propre rôle et
ensuite
et pas ton propre rôle de jouer vraiment
genre je te dis tu es un gars en soirée
je te vois bien dans un rôle de Bouli
ouf
à une soirée un peu genre tu es un peu
en mal alpha genre
on a pas de dos si on a de l'eau en plus
j'ai jamais pensé quand je dis jamais
c'est à dire que mon expérience est
arrêtée à l'arbre quand j'avais 12 ans
je peux te demander un arbre aussi
je peux très bien le faire ok en vrai
non si jamais posé la question mais par
contre tu sais qu'il y a un film où je
peux te faire jouer un arbre ah ouais
j'ai une petite idée franchement je peux
jouer l'herbe franchement
il y a des témoins ce que je vais là je
m'entraîne mais je peux jouer sans
problème là ok ça reviendra ça peut
mettre une voix d'arbre ah je peux faire
une voix d'arbre sans problème ok bon je
suis très content qu'ils sont engagés
je pense que la revanche est méritait tu
veux le dire vas-y je le dis alors que
la France est plongée dans un
confinement sans fin Justine 30 ans ne
trouve plus de sens à sa vie un soir
après les applaudissements à 20h elle
tombe sur un poste LinkedIn qui va
changer sa vie
il y a une il y a une ref ou c'est
vraiment vraiment un pitch pas trop mal
en fait
plus de sens à sa vie un soir après les
applaudissements à 20h elle tombe sur un
poste LinkedIn qui va changer sa vie
donc potentiellement un job quoi qui va
changer sa vie pour moi il y a un truc
de dans le titre avec les boomers de
Linkedin sur le côté
la vibe entrepreneur de Linkedin quoi
c'est très boomer Linglin c'est plus du
tout je crois qu'il y a tout je suis sur
Linkedin tu vois mais il y a je pense
qu'il y a tout quoi mais c'est un peu la
vibe jeune entrepreneur tu vois est-ce
qu'on peut pousser alors que la France
est sur Linkedin toi
Justine 30 ans ne trouve pas ça il est
dur ce pitch les gars c'est un vrai
pitch il y a moins de jeux de mots en
fait ah bah oui c'est ça qui est dommage
en fait
[Musique]
en 2300 la terre est à toi faut que tu
fasses derrière
tu vas faire des trucs un peu épiques
genre
en 2300 la Terre a été touchée par une
météorite et seuls les personnes
coiffées d'une coupe mulet ont survécu
10 ans après la catastrophe Maurice l'un
des survivants fait la rencontre d'une
femme plutôt étrange qui me ressemble à
personne d'autre on est pas mal du coup
j'ai pas du tout écouté
un cataclysme une les gens qui ont
survécu ont un mulet et Maurice un des
sur un des survivants avec une coupe à
mulet fait la rencontre d'une femme
étrange qui ne ressemble pour le coup à
personne d'autre puisque elle a
comment il s'appelle ce film déjà une
météorite
je crois que c'est le premier titre
c'était only new let ah ouais ouais
parce que c'était vraiment le pitch de
base où il y avait plus que des coupes
mulets ou Maurice et son gros mulet
ouais il y avait Maurice et son gros
mulet mais je crois que finalement il
l'avait enlevé parce que tu as aussi un
titre de film porno ils avaient pas les
droits ça dit qu'elle s'appelle comment
la fille la fille elle s'appelle c'est
pas lire en fait toi c'est le seul
problème Hugo décrypte ne sait pas lire
j'ai un iPad il lit rien et en fait il a
juste retenu par coeur
il a pas de prénom
Maurice et la femme étrange Maurice et
la femme étrange c'est la version film
d'auteur qu'ils avaient fait ouais c'est
un peu plus classique
et le Maurice et l'Iran quoi de sa femme
ça c'est la version avec Bigard qu'ils
avaient fait aussi ils ont fait plein de
montage en fer il savait pas ce qu'il
voulait très bien très fort merci
beaucoup je crois qu'il reste une
dernière un dernier petit truc
on va voir ce qu'il y a derrière
c'est un tweet un tweet qui date de 2020
justement confinement
je comprends pas pourquoi cette dame
disait elle attendait un mail de ta part
je sais pas toujours pas reçu de mail
depuis que je vois quoi à mon avis je ne
savais pas non plus et c'est pour ça que
là la réponse ou je me suis dit
peut-être elle veut savoir
de jouer à quoi Mario Kart principal tu
joues vraiment j'aime bien ouais je
j'aime bien et alors j'ai des enfants
maintenant donc c'est un peu réduit le
temps de jeu mais je pars où je regrette
de par chez Zelda voilà mais j'ai envie
de m'y mettre
j'adore Mario Kart bon niveau ou non je
suis nul j'adore juste y jouer OK et
pour mon anniv ma meuf avait fait un
super cadeau c'est que elle m'avait
invité au MK2 paradis donc un super
hôtel et il y a notamment une salle que
qu'elle m'avait privatisée pour mon
anniv avec tous mes potes et on pouvait
jouer à Mario Kart sur un écran grand
comme ça à peu près je te propose qu'on
fasse ça en fait
ah mais je crois qu'il est sérieux
quoi
c'est exceptionnel que j'ai parlé de ça
j'avoue que c'est un très très bon
souvenir je suis ravi de faire ça c'est
trop fort alors j'ai beaucoup de mal à
jouer
on va le découvrir ensemble sachant que
je crois qu'en plus il y a des gages
alors les gages les gars j'ai compris ok
je serais ravi de te voir le faire
les gars je crois c'est simple c'est
super oui tu devras faire une petite
apparition dans les actus du jour mais
l'apparition ça peut être pour faire la
promo de ton film donc globalement c'est
un cadeau je vais perdre
et si je perds tu vas me faire le oui
non que je t'ai fait tout à l'heure OK
dans 60 secondes ok mais c'est des
questions qui ont été préparées par
l'équipe ok je sais pas ce que c'est ok
je peux rajouter des questions à moi
aussi était obligé de répondre et je
suis obligé de répondre j'adore
parce que je vais te poser des questions
privées que tout le monde se pose et tu
auras jamais envie de monter
[Musique]
je comprends rien je fais quoi bleu non
je pense c'est bon
là-dedans non pas du tout attaché à la
console Ciao
[Musique]
et là on va commencer
là on est bon là on choisit nos
personnages je vais prendre le Mario
mais un peu mystère il est mieux ah
c'est Mario
mascarade de Mario tu sais quoi en bon
mascara je vais prendre lui franchement
c'est trop bien ce que vous me faites là
c'est un vrai petit cadeau attends je
vais me mettre bien
et on voit bien qu'ils ont bien visité
Paris ça fait plaisir ça ressemble en
rien c'est c'est Disneyland pour moi
ouais du coup tu as plus le temps de
jouer oh j'ai pas canon moins le temps
de jouer je pense ça va se voir très
vite d'ailleurs après il y en a qui part
par là et d'autres par là par la musique
parisienne je peux crever on fait qu'une
seule course et c'est comment le c'est
comment freiner déjà ou déraper
tu prends sur ce petit ton c'est parce
que tu crois mais c'est le côté j'ai
fait les Assassin's Creed et Far Cry
j'adore aussi oh Far Cry j'adore et mon
dernier Far Cry il a planté figure-toi
et apparemment c'est un bug commun donc
si les gens veulent m'aider ils peuvent
m'écrire sur Instagram comment me sortir
de cette panade je suis sur Playstation
c'est la dernière c'est la non j'ai la 4
ou alors si tu as une exclu avec Sony
j'ai la 6 non j'ai vraiment la 4 et je
suis bloqué mon Far Cry est bloqué ça a
été un grand tragédie parce que j'adore
Far Cry sur le dernier Far Cry j'ai
appris que tu avais appris à danser dans
un lieu un peu particulier ouais pour
mascarade ah oui c'est vrai plus ou pas
en fait je devais apprendre du coup à
vraiment danser avec une chorégraphe et
comme je devais finalement faire une
chorégraphie
dans le film sur du sable elle m'a dit
serait bien qu'on puisse répéter sur du
sable et donc moi j'ai dit bah je sais
pas où aller et elle m'a dit bah moi non
plus proche de Paris et en fait je dis
ah mais si à côté de chez moi comme je
suis à la campagne je lui ai dit il y a
des chevaux et du coup ce que je te
propose c'est qu'on se retrouve dans un
haras de chevaux et du coup avant de se
retrouver sur une magnifique plage de la
Côte d'Azur on a vraiment littéralement
répété dans du crottin de cheval tu es
devenu bon en danse mais en vrai on le
voit je suis devenu bon en cheval mais
c'est moi non est-ce que tu es moins
utile pour le film non non je suis du
coup en attendant du crottin et c'était
c'était un peu c'était marrant mais
après on pour les gens je vous rassure
on vous a réservé vraiment le côté
plutôt cool et beau à l'image dans ce
film qui est très beau d'ailleurs je
tiens à le dire et qui vraiment a de la
gueule d'enfer et je suis devenu bon en
danse écoute j'ai vraiment kiffé ça
j'avais jamais fait et j'ai vraiment
adoré ça je suis 7e tout simplement
c'est on peut s'en parler c'est moi il
peut y avoir mais comment je comment
pourrais-je avoir déjà voilà dites-moi
ça je sais que c'est vraiment les
questions vraiment de gars qui c'est pas
joué mais tu accélères pourtant
plus que ça juste ça ne veut pas quoi
c'est quand ça veut pas ça veut pas je
peux pas dépasser un gars juste pour
voir merci juste pour être sixième
et tu t'en vas et je suis là alors tout
seul dans le ciné je suis sixième c'est
dramatique comment je pète aussi nul
franchement tu es bon bon je suis
meilleur en dans ce cas Mario Kart j'ai
adoré faire ça et c'était vraiment une
nouvelle manière de m'exprimer que
j'avais jamais fait dans un film il
m'avait vraiment dit Nicolas Bedos on va
faire comme si c'était un monologue une
déclaration d'amour à ma partenaire et à
Margot dans le film mais que avec des
mouvements et donc on a travaillé ça
comme ça et c'était vraiment passionnant
à faire et allez voir le film et vous me
direz ce que vous pensez des scènes avec
de la danse le truc le plus dur que tu
as eu à apprendre dans un film c'était
quoi
peut-être la danse c'était vraiment dur
quand même et peut-être aussi la planche
des pompiers là il y a une planche tu
sais à mettre équestre de mettre même et
tu dois sauter et il faut la monter
comme ça d'un coup sans poser les 100 tu
peux poser les coudes si tu peux poser
les coudes d'ailleurs j'ai n'importe
quoi heureusement mais il faut que tu
montes sans t'aider des jambes
c'est chaud et les montées de corde
aussi des pompiers c'était dur très bien
on remercie cette magie du Miss
projection pardon de Mario Kart merci
désolé pour tous les passionnés de Mario
Kart même sur twitch les ponces Antoine
Daniel etc qui nous ont regardé pardon
et je viens de comprendre que je suis 7
sur 12 ce qui n'est pas si nul je
croyais vraiment qu'on était moins dans
la course non tu es sixième ça c'est le
sixième en plus ah regardez je regardais
les c'était un vrai boom
je n'ai vraiment il faut que je me
remette au jeu vidéo là c'est là que je
réalise que c'était très fort mais du
coup ça veut dire que tu as un petit
gage faudra parler d'une façon d'une
autre on verra OK dans les actus du jour
pour parler du film ça me va ce sera
très rapide mais ce sera ça me va après
tout de suite la promo franchement c'est
un très bon gage c'est un gage très
classe tranquille bon tu as plus c'était
trop bien merci beaucoup j'écoute je
t'écoute tous les jours c'est vrai
vraiment j'écoute les actus j'écoute je
regarde les interviews et tout bien donc
j'étais ravi de faire ce formateur j'ai
grave sympa franchement on a pu échanger
sur plein de sujets c'est un bon moment
trop cool trop cool merci à toi ouais
ben merci à toi merci aux équipes
courage pour la suite je rappelle du
coup mascarade ça sort le premier ventes
oui je l'ai vu as-tu aimé j'ai aimé j'ai
vraiment aimé n'hésitez pas à y aller en
date avec un pote avec une pote avec un
groupe de potes avec votre famille que
sais-je en tout cas
vraiment c'est un très beau film et
généreux dans la proposition de cinéma
on est devant un grand écran donc j'en
parle donc je pense que il y a moyen de
vraiment qui fait c'était cool et merci
aussi à MK2 encore une fois que tu nous
a accueilli encore merci Pierre merci à
toi à bientôt à très vite merci à vous
d'avoir regardé tout ça et on se tient
au courant pour la suite